il ya avec nous ce soir stéphane qui est
pompier qui est papa de trois enfants
qui a très peur du vaccin et de l'avenir
de ses enfants pour lui rendre la
vaccination obligatoire pour les enfants
ce serait un drame hier vous êtes montés
sur le toit de votre caserne pour
contester contre tout ça avant de vous
faire déloger par le le gign
trop vous avez fait ça
ben en fait on est dans une impasse
ouais et vous êtes pompiers donc
aujourd'hui oui en fait voilà je suis
j'ai commencé pompiers j'avais 16 ans
ouais
j'en ai 46 donc ça fait 30 ans de
pompiers de paris j'ai fait dix huit
décès de 18 ans pour lui paris d'accord
donc je suis à la retraite des pompiers
de paris et je suis en pompier
volontaire à la caserne bab lit dans le
78 d'accord et vous pourquoi pourquoi
vous avez aussi peur du vaccin ben en
fait j'ai vu des trucs vous avez nombre
a pour le moment où le poids de réseaux
sociaux tous sont d'accord
moi ce que je vois c'est que pour le
vaccin là actuellement j'ai mon dernier
mon petit dernier qui a treize ans non
mais lol a bola
il devait rentrer à chartres donc ils
sont trés métro gamins sont très grandes
balles le
donc le dernier devait rentrer à
chartres en cod donc c'est le centre
d'entraînement départemental
mais à 13 ans il partait de la maison à
l'internât est là en deux jours dont
j'étais encore sur le toit quand ma
femme m'a envoyé le sms mais comme
j'avais promis ou bien du gign qui se
fait ici parce qu'ils sont très très
bons
il
m'a envoyé un sms comme quoi le iron
version un message le
il faut le passer iter à partir du 30
septembre pour mon gamin qui en section
donne donc alors moi comme on peut pas
le faire vacciner donc ben ali veut lui
ne veut pas que les sélections loin
possible de ne payer chaque île à quatre
entraînements par semaine trois jours
donc on va doter sport c'est donc vous
allez faire quoi mais vous 5 l'image
était très forte de voir imprimé à
monter sur le toit de sa caserne on va
la voir un l'image et page et ont tous
deux mois vous avez honte de vous ou vie
n'a rien à regarder on va voir on va
voir si
la prochaine normalement jusque rien
parce que parce que je suis non violent
qui presque à je trouve le falher de
public je fais que ne pas m'alimenter en
fait tant que c'est plus parlant je
pense qu'une manifestation quand tu es
tu vraiment sincère
et honnête
en fait fini dans youtube heures parce
que toi je m'achète ou non bon courage à
tous les pompiers de france en fait tous
les soignants de france
et tous les gamins qui vont être obligés
de les relaxer pour faire leur sport
à l'est pas plus tiens
c'est vrai que cette image qui est très
forte elle a beaucoup tourné oui laurent
alexandre faudrait peut-être un peu plus
dédramatiser moi j'ai fait vacciner tous
mes enfants j'ai fait vacciner tous les
enfants aient compris mes enfants
mineurs j'ai pas eu le moindre doute et
je suis médecin et j'ai pas eu le
moindre doute en tant que citoyen en
tant que père de famille et en tant que
père de famille nombreuse vraiment cette
angoisse sur le vaccin elle est
déraisonnable et les effets secondaires
qu'on a aujourd'hui sont absolument
infime on a extrêmement peu d'effets
secondaires je n'ai pas hésité une
seconde à faire vacciner mes propres
enfants est vraiment n'ayez pas cette
inquiétude en retour en parlions prix
voulais c'était franchement il faut pas
paniquer pour ce vaccin juste et parce
que nous avons sont trés trés ému par
cette vidéo je vous serai ému par cette
vidéo vous aurez vu part ça on est à
cran tout le monde est à cran au trio
d'attaquants mais mal après pour
répondre monsieur
moi mes trois gamins alors les délais
le premier majeur depuis peu
moi j'en ai trois si je le fais vacciner
et malheureusement comme nous il ya
beaucoup de gamins condé péricardite
j'en connais un deux mois les restes à
l'hôpital 17 ans ils étaient volontaires
pour sa cuisine il ya ces deux mois
l'hôpital en dordogne et je fais quoi
vous sais pas où tu pleures oui en fait
je sais pas d'effets secondaires on a
aujourd'hui a fait quoi mais si c'est
mon gamin c'est un gamin revient est
effectivement une cocarde et epernay
pour l'instant il y avait aucun décès
n'a lisons tout été résolus mais là
c'est à dire que ça s'est réglé avec un
traitement simple et m'en fous on a
aujourd'hui ça c'est simple on a
aujourd'hui ex-milieu finalement peu
d'effets secondaires en flandre est
vraiment moi dans le père de famille je
n'ai eu aucune hésitation et et vraiment
je vous incite à regarder de près les
chiffres exacts mois si jamais il y
avait eu le moindre doute jamais
j'aurais fait vacciner mais pauvre gamin
j'ai pas envie mes gamins alors que je
suis médecin que je prenais les effets
seconde alors attendez c'est fort invite
sacrifier mes gars alors au niveau élevé
si j'ai fait vacciner mes enfants c'est
vraiment le vaccin est très sûr